I was you know devout Dick Smith fan met
dick when I was 18 years old
anybody who knows me pretty much knows
the story I'm told so many times but we
would correspond and dick would always
tell me what his future projects were
and he said I was going to work on this
movie based on a best-selling book by
William Peter Blatty called The Exorcist
so I immediately did something very out
of character for me I went out and
bought a book and read it which is a
little hard because I'm kind of a little
bit dyslexic but I I was fascinated by
the book in the end I just couldn't wait
to see what dick was gonna bring to this
and how he was going to visualize Reagan
and dick sent me some photos of some
tests which I thought were really cool
and dick was pretty much a one-man show
he worked in his basement in his house
in Larchmont New York and he had
prepared all the you know makeups like
this it's so used once and throw away a
foam rubber piece you glue on once you
throw it away you have a new piece for
every day they're cast in a mold it
takes you know a day to find out if your
previous day's casting actually work so
dick had prepared all the appliances for
Linda Blair all the appliances for max
Juancito at least to get started and and
I think was the first day that Linda was
in makeup dick had the original concept
makeup on which was very different than
what's in the final film and one of the
crew said oh she's got her mask on now -
which Billie freaking the director of
the film heard that and looked at it and
said this is two masks II do another one
and dick I mean it was panic because
they were in production you know and he
like I said he had prepared four months
to do all this stuff so that worked out
to my advantage dick didn't know how he
was going to be doing makeups on the set
and preparing stuff in his laboratory so
you remember this kooky kid in
California that that was you know a real
makeup fan he called me up and said you
know I'm I'm in a bind and I was hoping
that maybe you could fly to New York
live in my house in
work in my basement to to help me on the
Exorcist and it was like on the phone in
opening up my underwear drawer and
packing my back at the same time and I
say you know gee I don't know I'm gonna
have to think about this dick but but I
was actually there when that makeup
evolved into what we all know and love
is Reagan's makeup and I first of all I
was appalled
I mean knows how could anybody question
Dick Smith you know and and what the
nerve that this man has to say that you
know he has to do another one you know
but I've actually you know he was right
and the makeup that they finally came up
with was much better for the film and I
kind of put that away that you know
maybe sometimes directors actually can
be right you know but I usually don't
remember that but but I actually you
know I watched it evolve and I sat there
and watched him try things on Lynda and
and and and saw the way and Peter Blatty
and and and Billy free can come in and
suggest stuff and and it was really an
interesting experience and and most of
my time you know I ended up making all
the molds for the new appliances and and
running the foam rubber for those and
running the foam rubber Max von Sydow
stuff and making duplicate molds for
that and most of my work was in dicks
basement laboratory but when the Iraq
sequence took place which was that after
all the New York shooting was done dick
asked me to come in and a system with
max when she does makeup my job as
assisting dick gun on Max's makeup was
pretty much holding a glue bottle for
him but I was there and I I got to watch
the master work and he let me make up
Max's hands with the old age tip on when
you see the movie there's a big close-up
in the this is this is my or I take
credit for this big closeup of his hand
when he finds the Pazuzu a little model
thing and in Iraq and that's me so I
expect a lot of applause there but said
but the reality is I was just a flunky
lab assistant for the master and for the
amazing man who conceived and executed
these makeups
you